oh hey I was going bros my name is bill
we're doing the last episode of inside
today look at that that's them that's
what we got to play next or have left or
whatever so it should be a pretty long
episode especially because I'll probably
[ __ ] up somehow and not knowing what to
do this thing is here I think I need to
get up in the water I don't know how to
do that this doesn't seem like there's
anything I can grab on to here this is a
really strange room
I've been appreciating all you bros
comments on theories I've been it's been
really interesting to read what you guys
thoughts and opinions are about the game
I think what's for sure is that everyone
that's watching this let's play or
playthrough is really into it and so am
i and that's really cool I hope I don't
[ __ ] up this last part because I am
actually stuck at this area let's see if
I can figure it out maybe I'm supposed
to go underneath here nope maybe we can
find something over here maybe there's a
box or something that we didn't bring
with us
there is something here suppose we
didn't go make no difference or doesn't
there's a button here that opens that
hatch why would we open that hatch
though okay what about this button then
okay this is a bigger puzzle guys that's
why we got it booked the all right let's
see where this takes this one is broken
we're gonna bring back the box I'm sure
of it
hi CJ puzzle okay so we pulled this up
and then we push it out at the right
time oh [ __ ] me I didn't know how to
[ __ ] it up that bad
Jesus if you love me I love no box okay
how do we do it now that we angle it
here cuz we need to bring it back man oh
man I'm scared I don't think I should
stand here oh that is adorable
alright so same puzzle again just go up
on it hole the thing and press the lever
or button whatever alright big your rug
[ __ ] button it's alright
shut up boom we just got ourself a box
okay
there's I didn't think I would be
walking backwards but then again it went
really fast I don't remember what we did
last episode so it was really
interesting how we would pull down by
the mermaid girl or whatever and what
really happened there it seemed like the
fishes were the ones that saved our
lives
some people point it out all right I'm
not sure how true that is
there's definitely something related to
water and dump step perhaps now it will
whack
I do not know let's give it a try maybe
we need to pull both that would make
sense or maybe not oh okay so how did we
pull both I suppose we pull this first
I think I timed it right actually I
think I timed it perfectly
now here a lot of question marks are
rise the gravity is upside down in this
place these people are alive could these
be the people that control other people
I don't know one theory that I thought
was interesting is that remember how
there were lots of creepy this place
remember how I was controlling someone
and then that person was controlling
someone which kind of opened up the
theory that even though we might not
think it or haven't seen any evidence of
it we might be controlled by someone and
if you go really philosophical or meta I
suppose I'm controlling the boy you know
I I wonder if there's a play on that I
don't know but it's it's an interesting
thought I don't know why I did this
Can I grab this
it's important maybe I can swim on
through now no I can't
god damn this is [ __ ] creepy
maybe we need this thing that I just I
died I [ __ ] that can't just do that
can't just swim downwards oh there's
another one here okay well good thing I
died then I suppose I think this should
change to gravity perhaps some sort of
gravity machine now why would you have
that I don't know we should dump stem
well I guess I'll guess I'll fit going
in here okay very cool [ __ ] that water
what is this structure it's so strange
you never know what you're gonna find
next and how is this gonna end you know
I'm so curious what's over here caged
some boxes
huh I heard a laugh that was creepy I
remember the ending of the ending of
limbo is so [ __ ] good I wonder if
they will have like a mind-blowing
ending just like that one I swear I hear
someone well
there are some people someone had this
strange theory about the phases this
guy's been control that there's a reason
we don't have a face or some [ __ ] like
that which I disagree with I think it's
just the design choice but someone
pointed out that the people that weren't
being controlled had more wearing masks
but it's interesting at you point they
you know it's true but I don't think
that's it
suppose only bringing this box wait is
it filled with water now oh there's
people there are they gonna see me
there's a camera this is like a test lab
of some sort
I was thinking aliens last episode but
I'm thinking more and more government
taking over at this stage look at that
that is really [ __ ] cool
okay let's place it there now we're in
the water strange strange strange game
well the people in the back are not
realising what the hell is happening to
be honest I am not quite sure as well we
can't seem to pull the Box down I hope I
don't die if I jump down here I don't
think I should know okay and now where's
the box where did the box ago I can't
see to be fair I felt like I struggled a
lot less on the puzzles I might be wrong
I feel like the puzzles were a little
nicer in this game than limbo limbo some
of the puzzles were pretty brutal
I remember getting really stuck on them
I'm sure as I said that I'm gonna get
stuck on this oh I'm so stupid
I'm so stupid I don't need the box over
there I need the box over here I kept
thinking I needed the box for the
[ __ ] door
come here box let me adjust you okay
don't squish me though and they'll [ __ ]
me okay if I understand correctly mr.
box come down to F mr. box do you really
love me improve it thank you
and that this [ __ ] ambience is so
creepy and now we will put the water
right before the door goes down which is
yeah then we can just jump up on the box
ah of kiss thank you this has got to be
so scary to swim with the surface
underneath you
that's so cool though alright alright I
made that way more complicated than it
needed to be I wish the boy could dive
and stuff I mean I wouldn't dive there
but we're not getting chased I'm so done
getting chased should we check what's
under the water just kind of curious
since we can since we're part of them
are oh my god is more people damn don't
let me do plus it whoa there's a person
there they're working underneath the
surface
could those really be maybe this is so
weird
oh I'm by the surface
okay okay now I am kind of a lost cause
here I don't know what the [ __ ] that was
all about I'm spinning the wheel not
entirely sure what it does I can't
really see what it oh okay I just had to
pull upwards Hey It's Raining Men
hallelujah it's wait what
oh they're attacking me now are they
following me they follow me it's it's
because I have that that though yellow
thing that was in the head implanted in
me so I don't need it for them to follow
me so these ones are under control but
why were they kept like that underwater
look at the [ __ ] fetus looking one
Jesus that is creepy man do I need him
what is that on the ground that his arms
all right well I'm the king of the
undead now this is really interesting
I like how their bodies are affected
they've been affected by all the water
you can tell oh there's the button here
you guys can lift me up lift me up come
on guys it's gotta be another way
Follow Me lads to victory listen I don't
even know why I'm doing this I just
wanted to escape but it doesn't seem
like it seems like I have another goal
you know cuz I begin to [ __ ] that
away this place maybe we need this
little fella hey buddy oh my god you
you're so creepy maybe we need the water
again all right guys hurry hurry hurry
okay we'll just stop there that makes
sense now we can just jump into the
water of course Oh [ __ ] course let's
do it here thanks guys just just wait
right there they're following me I
wonder where the fishes were following
me in the same way as these guys were
you know what I mean right after we got
implanted or whatever and why did we get
implanted I have so many questions it's
the kind of game that doesn't tell you I
kind of loved and hated at the same time
hey we got more people more workers look
at the janitor
i'ma follow this guy now [ __ ] yeah
follow me
everything is so right I'll be the one
who check you in it Nate that's right oh
my god
you distracted me they can't die though
maybe maybe we need to trick them to go
down first and then we'll bill catches
as I'm [ __ ] that'd be pretty funny guys
I'm gonna have to time we need a
volunteer oh this is gonna be funny
alright gonna have to push one down and
so I mean they're so cute hey Bernie
this is sparta oh [ __ ] I fell down [ __ ]
[ __ ] catch me you're supposed to catch
how are they limped so strong maybe the
water I don't know I'm just making [ __ ]
up at this point cuz I don't [ __ ]
know oh man okay guys I need you I need
you to jump down Barney Barney sorry my
phone I should have muted it but Bernie
honestly [ __ ] jump down Barney why am
i calling you Bernie
the naka they could could you throw me
to the other side maybe well that was a
lot [ __ ] easier oh then you just go
down anyway well [ __ ] me then oh I've
seen this on the trailer isn't this
where you look at all that okay let's
take a minute here what are we looking
at a mega structure underneath the water
it's people running why are people
running
something's happen we don't know the
context of what is happening when is
happening and why it's happening people
are moving could be controlled
probably it's controlled who is control
who's not control I don't know
now I'm gonna jump here down there and
hope that you guys [ __ ] catch me you
guys are the [ __ ] best y'all get a
promotion get me up there Thanks see you
later losers
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] okay are we
gonna open for them here I sure hope so
cuz I really like these guys there's
there's a blood trail here I see it this
could be dangerous
Oh No
oh they're above me I see them
could you guys come down there no they
can what if I press the button yeah
that's it no oh I can direct them on the
floors here
I saw it I think I sigh still again I'll
just keep pushing here Neera I don't
know what the goal is
hahaha um sir
Annie okay now they're walking above me
that seems like a hint doesn't it
hey my buddies alright run the same page
follow me
Lisa you got a nice bride that Victoria
Secrets you are working it totally you
look so good this guy's looked like they
had a little bit too much to drink
potentially like your hat though
safety first ever right
even though they're being controlled
even though they can't break their limbs
their workers has hat on the music
changed seems like we're gonna have to
yeah get some help here thanks guys you
guys rock oh oh [ __ ] okay we're here now
this is where we looked out through the
window sorry Bernie it's always brown
isn't it we're definitely getting to the
end I can feel it
and such a great concept I'm so
intrigued by everything that's happening
hi guys thank you I'll come back for you
I'll come back for you you don't
understand me I love the mystery and all
the giant buildings and structures and
everything it's so interesting what do
they do in here playing video games will
the Warcraft games guess I'll go through
that a golf cart
whoa whoa what some kind of study here
of a test subject people are running it
looks like they're fleeing
I'm really curious why are people
fleeing because this everything looks so
abandoned you know no one is at work
what went wrong
did something went wrong who is this
some tests what would they show to an
audience whatever they were showing you
clearly failed here's some more whoa
whoa is this guy trying to catch me no
he's not
whoa that's freaky man
why are they running why are they
running
this ladder here Oh everyone is running
to look at the thing oh my god what is
gonna happen I've seen this in the
trailer but I don't know what's in there
let's have a look what no we don't get
to see it yet
okay so they're not escaping it seems
more like they might be a bit of neon
genesis evangelion just in the sense of
like the defense like the envy it has
the same feeling that everything just
kind of [ __ ] up and they're just kind
of one because they're not celebrating
whatever is happening doesn't seem like
it's good
should we try and just get up here it
seems like it everyone is too busy to
notice that I'm doing mirrors edge [ __ ]
right now it looks like we're going to
where they are looking what is our goal
here oh my god I'm sorry if I'm annoying
with all the questions this is where
they were looking the other all looking
down there we're sneaking right now so
try and be careful I suppose
do they look they did
they're too busy they seem a lot less
into getting me caught ah come on
we have to know what they saw I think
we're going down there it seems like it
cut that's cool
can't obviously can't lift it
yeah there's this huge structure
should we jump down there seems a little
crazy we did it oh my god they are
really building up the tension man
really building the tension in curiosity
seems very unsafe I [ __ ] it
I don't want to talk too much
this is such a high
important moment
okay jump in the water we're going in
guys we're going in why are we going in
you know he seems so intent on it
literally won't walk anywhere else I'll
look anywhere else
maybe we should back off
I'm nervous why am i nervous
I forget something there's a stream of
water so I can't swim down whoa got
quiet go any guys we don't have a lot of
time
gotta wait for it to open completely
look at this it's art
we need the fun again maybe it has a
timed on it that would make sense
so we hurry up go down swing before it
the fan starts properly oh my god listen
to the music
say
I got goose bumps
here we go I'm naked what happened to my
clothes this is where they were looking
this is their cheering
the cheering why what is this oh my god
that is definitely a bunch of humans
mushed together into a ball they I want
to make a joke that it's a Swedish
meatball but goddamnit that it's like a
hive mind is it the hive mind like
control it would make sense I get sucked
in
ah no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way I'm
controlling this yeah they're not
cheering anymore hi guys
jacksepticeye here I'm a giant Swedish
meatball
well they sure as hell doesn't answer
any questions just begs for more what
can we do is this guy maybe we have more
powers now
maybe pulled o depend the house maybe
now we can leave
oh no we walk we walk
she said
oh it's inside all right oh my joy
we were controlled by this thing from
the beginning
I think that's why we're walking
straight towards a
I think that was a
trying to do this from the beginning
where I came from and why I don't know
these guys should keep following us I
think it's probably so it's probably the
same technology that we made but it got
out of hand or some [ __ ]
obviously I don't think this is I
wouldn't call this anything else
what that [ __ ] man I shouldn't be more
surprised but I'm still so intrigued
it's not the strip club
oops a little bit too much to drink
oh no that is [ __ ] disgusting
okay [ __ ] means business
what are we doing
so before they were celebrating I don't
think they're doing that anymore
good old puzzles good old puzzles I'll
put you down there buddy oh my [ __ ]
god this thing is turning me on so much
like I am so turned on by this thing I
want it and I want to eat it it looks
delicious
hi everybody
oh my god
chairman CEO sup sorry about that man my
bad Hey look I got a new skirt I better
wash it up god damn it I hate when I get
blood on my new skirt well I guess I'll
bring this now it's on my leg [ __ ] it I
have like 400 of them I'm controlling
this
we're gonna do I I see how it is is like
Lord of the Rings hold it up hold it
study guys we're gonna [ __ ] barricade
not barricade all right now hold it up
hold it up like that not like that guys
I need you to work together as a team
you're a team now
that's exactly what I try to do [ __ ]
dogs out to get me
[ __ ] you dogs lucky dogs you don't know
me
alright guys I'm a Z excuse me eskesen
what alright thank you very much
[ __ ] this thing is heavy man this is
loli limbo do I need this high role this
is all wrong
okay so
can you dog this [ __ ] off
see a bit of a [ __ ]
Miep overall the galaxy cannonball
ow lost my ankles
Jesus Christ hey man could you help me
oh he needs to escape we need to let him
escape
he's scared coming for your bed ha ha ha
ah come on don't chicken out Jesus
Christ let me have some fun come on it's
safe Jesus just go just get No
Babbitt I'm f ed up f ed up pop it up
pop it up up up up
fits like a glove No hey [ __ ] [ __ ]
you I'm not going down there well I
guess I will go down there then I want
mommy
[ __ ] hurt more boxes and [ __ ] oh it's
one of these it's that an incinerator
that's a jet fuel that's some jet fuel
[ __ ] man there's a [ __ ] work man
I meatball Oh meatball this is the
craziest [ __ ] ending ever honestly
most unexpected all right what am I
missing here I think we just need a
little bit of fire here you see the
engine and the thing in the back is
cleared it running just don't know what
the [ __ ] to do with this box take it
take me to like the Human Centipede vibe
there's something there very hidden
though let's try that again
a box you're the best man I wonder if
the meatball floats or not you're coming
with me box just cuz I love you mr. box
isn't the meatballs best friend
incinerator we go into the [ __ ]
incinerator I knew it we just have to
die we just have to [ __ ] die that is
amazing I feel like I'm getting a
sunburn just need a little bit more
speed and then we're almost there the
sweet release of death is almost there
baby
we need like the witch from Hans and
Greta maybe burn the box should we burn
the box
now the boxes on fire [ __ ] hurts ah I
don't like it
maybe this opens something over here oh
we need to bring that the fire okay I
get it I get it
the question is how we bring the box
through the fire we could throw it above
it that's probably it
okay so let's try and throw it
what a catch let's try again
what
[ __ ] yeah hell yeah that was awesome
this thing burns ah you hold it Lisa I'm
limited to about two words two names
Rubert and Lisa all right now we're
gonna let this place get about to get
likk yo hey and now we can go through
they're all looking at me it's like they
realize I'm not technical yes right
there's nothing they can do I mean just
a giant meatball I'm gonna live down my
life the way I want to live it you know
look at these guys can I get a hand cuz
like it doesn't seem like they're trying
to stop me or maybe they are come on
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys Wow Wow look
here a little minecart
hmm that you weren't expecting that from
a meatball excuse me while I grab on to
this coming for you lads are we gonna
swing it very gonna swing it Lance
are they gonna help me I wonder if
they're gonna help me this will be
really interesting
they know where I'm going
they know where I'm going it seems like
it oh man ok this guy's helping me
look at him he wants to anyone says to
throw it to him
he was like it's okay you guys [ __ ]
Rock he's that go thanks buddy
see ya oh I have to hurry up my bad
alright we'll have to do this again yeah
yeah I'm a meatball I'm never smart
sorry
and there it is we are through are there
people in the background why are they
doing this someone is controlling this
we can't quite reach it they wanted us
to fall they are there they trapped us
that's not bad
we're still a meatball though Oh No
I think the egg is about to hatch guys
know okay we see something now what is
happening can we swim up
I am Not sure oh you guys didn't trap me
at all
y'all need we're out in the wild baby
fishes doesn't seem to like me anymore I
don't know why just because I'm ugly
maybe they're just leading the way I
don't [ __ ] know there fishes Jesus
Christ
the Fisher's have a I rely on them we
developed a fish trap
that's our detail this game is
nice morning bath god damn the noises
these guys make Babbitt about that bed
up that bad up habit of FF with him you
like worse than the monster hey let's do
that again that was pretty good meatball
power yeah [ __ ] hell really like
Jennifer we're a [ __ ] Boulder okay we
made it out through the factory to the
light I can't control it
what's gonna happen don't just end on me
what is happening I can't move
I can't move we're right by the end
I think this might be the end
no [ __ ] way it ends like this
we just wanted to tan we just wanted to
[ __ ] have a tan oh man that is an
interesting question to say the least
you Danish [ __ ] weirdos I'm just
kidding
oh boy that was a trick that was an
adventure that was incredible I don't
know if anything else is gonna happen
with these guys so I want to speak too
soon but I think if you watch it this
far I think we all can agree that this
was an amazing game I loved it from the
beginning to the end it was you can tell
they improved a lot from limbo for me
this is a much superior title and I
think that says a lot really really cool
thank you so much for watching this
let's play leave your theories in the
comments
I need to think about it
I don't want to speak too soon
you know
I hope I'm not missing anything in
obvious here because I understood the
ending of limbo they clicked you know
this hasn't clicked for me but I'm
trying to see what's happening it's
almost like we're a seed you know and
we're giving like a plant way it's
something happening there oh there is
more happening it looks like the kind of
slug thing in from the beginning doesn't
it
it looked like we were like this being
that needed to do some like this evolved
creature that needed something to kind
of oh that's where it ends well I don't
know I really don't know like I said I
would love to think about it for a bit
and read ebro's thoughts regardless
thank you bros so much for watching this
playthrough I really really appreciate
it it's been a blast I love that I can
play games that I'm really passionate
about and share those experience with
you online because I think that's a
really cool thing and that's it's it's
way more enjoyable for me and I hope you
enjoyed as well check out the game
support these developers ah not just
like obviously this is kind of kind of
games I love and I would love to see
more of it and that's it that's it for
now and as always I'll see Bros in the
next playthrough stay awesome breasts
for you by such
Hey